la defensa de pedro castillo ha
presentado un recurso de nulidad a la
investigación que la fiscalía ha abierto
en contra del mandatario por las
acusaciones del ex ministro del interior
marino gonzález esta tarde el presidente
castillo ha asegurado que su gobierno no
tiene tiempo para escándalos he
conversado con algunos juristas y ellos
me han señalado que en realidad pedro
castillo se siente muy seguro porque
hasta el momento solamente existen
acusaciones pero ninguna prueba
contundente contra él y en realidad casi
o sabe perfectamente que el parlamento
no dispone de los 87 votos que se
requieren para someterlo a un proceso de
impeachment o vacancia presidencial como
es conocido en perú hoy el congreso
peruano citó a varios funcionarios para
esclarecer las denuncias de presunta
corrupción que sigue será pues para
castillo podría enfrentar un proceso de
destitución
bueno en realidad esta tarde los
miembros de la comisión de fiscalización
han adjuntado los testimonios recabados
hoy al proceso de acusación
constitucional contra pedro castillo
pero por el momento no van a avanzar a
nada más por lo que se ha visto a
diversos congresistas ellos solamente
están interesados por ahora en la
elección de la nueva mesa directiva del
parlamento que en reunir firmas para un
proceso de impeachment contra casey o en
realidad ellos saben que lo que viene es
tratar de ganar tiempo y en ese sentido
como no tienen los votos necesarios dos
congresistas han presentado un proyecto
de ley que buscaría reducir los votos
necesarios que son 87 a 68 a 78 esto
sería a través de una modificación al
reglamento del parlamento que pretenden
realizar